[Music]
robbed just last week you were watching
a battlefront 2 video that kind of
caught my eye there's loot crate's
coming up in battlefront 2 when it
launches in November but also some
slightly more possibly concerning aspect
to this progression system first off lay
the basis for what is going on in this
game's progression the basis well battle
means like the foundation sure sure sure
the battlefield 1 had Luke rapes but
they were purely cosmetic this time
around they are well they're the star
cards the power-ups that you got from
the previous iteration did you mean to
say battlefront 1 did I say what did I
said well about comparing battlefield 1
which was purely cosmetic you know here
is now the progression with like star
cards so ok so basically just to clarify
for people watching this b-roll is from
I believe they it was a disclaimer like
a page a youtuber yeah a youtuber say
you know the idea to matter his name is
battlefront updates so here you see
basically these different types cards so
you you get a loot which you give to
credits credits you earn through matches
what you get from a loot crate can be
anything from star cards which are
abilities each class has two specific
you know like permanent abilities and
then you have what an option basically
just swap out with one of these earned
star cards you get through a loot crate
you can also get credits apparently and
crafting parts so if I were to get for
instance like an assault training star
card which booths boost my health every
kill I get there are different like
fashions of that star part so I could
get a common card a uncommon to rare to
epic epic being like for the example
given here I think was like an epic star
card which I can upgrade with crafting
it's an epic would give me Quarian
grammy like 40 health if i give for
every kill opposed to like common which
is 20 mm-hmm so the point being that
like you randomly get like this assault
card right I can put that for a specific
class I can upgrade that with crafting
parts that I can get through dupes or
again like just randomly through these
loot crate's
so if I get a duplicate loot crate I can
convert that to crafting parts and then
I could basically manually like pick
that said star card and upgrade it to
epic I think the problem however is that
the other rarity card is legendary
legendaries are purely random and
through loot crate's
which like a lot of games have legendary
items but they are cosmetic right like a
overwatch has a lot of the higher tier
aesthetics for each character but again
they're not gonna affect the gameplay
just what you see so that's where this
becomes a little bit potentially
problematic unless there's something
huge we're not seeing and as you can pay
to get legendary items ostensibly
through paying for credits with real
world money so that's why your imagine
that's what you have to imagine I
through microtransactions that like
there will be legendary loot crate's
that will grant me and or guarantee me a
legendary star card they're random but
of course the more obviously the more
money you pay the more likely you are to
get them through the system so you could
be playing someone that instead of
paying like a hundred dollars to
eventually get this specific Han Solo
skin you're gonna be playing against
someone who paid a hundred dollars to
get this specific ability that can wreck
everybody you're standing around yeah
this is all hype those are like
hypothetical situations but that's what
it sounds like this is moving toward
because you actually pay for abilities
and powers in game in a multiplayer
setting that can potentially be
imbalanced by real world money yeah I
mean and it's a it's a matter also of
balancing these cards right so like in
another video this guy had of like three
put out he was showing like I believe it
was like I was like a stealth card but
basically it would like double he was
comparing like the epic to like the
common and it was pretty significant as
far as the melee damage it was doing it
was like
like I posted like without the card it
was like takes like four hits or like
three hits to kill someone and this guy
was doing it in like two oh my god but
that you know that can be balanced I'm
sure they're they're constantly already
doing that but yeah I mean it's it's
concerning like you know again you said
it like you know I'm all for loot
crate's it for cosmetics like that's
fine but I I wonder if one of the issues
I was telling someone this is like maybe
they like they would have definitely you
know maybe they would have loved to have
done like a cosmetic system but you
think might Star Wars and the blandness
with like just you know original trilogy
stormtroopers like you I really don't
want to see you know pink tiger skin
clone troopers walking around like yours
yeah purely weapons say like scopes
maybe like or maybe something like
different grips I mean but to what
extent is that is that gonna work for
them is that gonna give them money
because they had to implement I guess
some kind of micro transaction if all of
their DLC is gonna be fair free it's
interesting because right it's more of a
bummer because seems like battlefront 2
was moving toward what made battlefield
1 good in terms of its progression right
you get weapon attachments and
everything through in-game currency but
it wasn't like something that completely
imbalances you and gives you extra
abilities but yeah I think you know in
the early 2000s kind of had this image
of being a money-grubber right with
microtransactions and everything and it
seems like now nobody has paid a win
because of the image it would the damage
it would do their games image it seems
like it's so weird that they might even
be considering this at this point yeah I
mean I think ultimately solutions to
this that would would help the situation
is if I am like what you don't want is
you don't want just like not have any
form of controlled progression right say
I'm like obsessed with flying and by
weight all the ships and vehicles
vehicles I'll also now have apparently
like weapons slots or like modifications
suppose the last time like you can kind
of customize your vehicle like you can't
be a battlefield one with skins and
loadouts but say as long as I if I can
focus on two
a task like a role or a class mm-hmm and
I can be guaranteed say maybe loot
crate's that are like specific to
vehicles like oh this one's gonna have
like a Naboo Starfighter skin because I
was flying a lot of that or maybe it's
gonna be a weapon loadout for that
hopefully that is a way I think the the
progression can kind of like outshine
from the randomness you know like if
it's kind of generalized loot crate's I
think that could be a possibility but I
don't know well injustice - did
something recently were because you
can't unlock a couple a few new
abilities for each character but there
if you don't get them randomly through
loot crate you can also just unlock them
without paying anything at levels 15 and
20 I believe for each character or
something and you unlock those abilities
so but there's also ranked matches where
those don't like certain things don't
your loot and your loadout does not
affect anything it's just the base
fundamental stats for each character the
same with destiny iron banner actually
takes an irk into account your loot and
so you could you know presumably have
worse loot than someone else there's
specific game modes where that loot
plays into the game so to me that would
be an easy way for battlefront to to
balance it like you can play this
playlist or this game mode where you
can't have these pay2win abilities
that's if you don't want that you have
the equivalent of like a ranked match
where everybody's playing at the sure
the same level playing field but outside
of destiny I can't think of many
shooters that do something like that but
it would it would make sense for this
game like it would be an easy way for
them to say oh if you don't want to do
this where someone could pay a hundred
dollars for this legendary ability or
whatever or this Canon slot on this tank
then go play the standard team
deathmatch playlist with no heroes so
maybe I hope it seems like that would be
the easiest way to justify it what seems
like a pay2win thing like maybe more
will come out and I'll you know I'll
have to like eat my word but that's what
it seems like right now especially after
that detailed video you guys and go
watch it was battlefront updates yeah
but it's right now it makes me a little
more worried than it was because I was
really looking forward to how
battlefield 1 and their dice title was
influencing battlefront yeah and like we
were talking a couple weeks ago about
like the hero system
being like just a random token that you
kind of get essentially killstreaks I
was hoping that loot would be more like
like you were saying robbed like a
weapon customization like oh if I want
like an extended mag or whatever it is
like I don't know that that wouldn't be
that but like whatever whatever it could
be like a scope because if you like
sniping maybe you want to customise your
weapon and that would be different than
oh this thing can kill you in two hits
instead of 15 and now I've just won the
match for the my team are you even think
about how it would like we could we kind
of left I felt like III with like a
pretty positive outlook on even like
yeah you'd mentioned heroes like oh it's
actually kind of easy or or easier to
take down Darth Maul or like one one of
these heroes will hero school now me
apparently you can customize these and
put legendary cards on them so they take
less damage you know or deliver more
damage like jeez that's gonna be fun
one of these guys with like all
legendary cards as Darth Maul just
wrecking shops like dad is worried and
can easily be a concern yeah but then
you see then a vertiginous pay $50 and
kill Darth Maul easier they wouldn't say
that but that's what it sounds like you
could do uh yeah so I guess I'm
personally concerned we'll see you and
what happens with it if they can figure
out a way to make it a little more of a
balanced playing field hopefully maybe I
just hopefully you know just you know
need to hear more about it to understand
epic but right now the question was is
it pay to win it seems like it might
possibly be might hear more about it we
will hear more about it as the game it's
November release yeah I'm still kind of
looking forward to it for sure
the story mode especially but let's see
how the progression everything goes
[Music]